during the world Marine Fort Blackbeard
violated one of the core beliefs of the
one piece world when he suddenly gained
the power of a second devil fruit and
this game-changing power made Blackbeard
one of the absolute strongest characters
in the world but have you ever wondered
what might happen if Luffy got to eat a
second devil fruit as well and what
fruit would actually be the perfect
combo to pair with his original Powers
while I was thinking about the absolute
best options and the very first fruit
that we're going to explore is Luffy's
second power is one of the most powerful
devil fruits in the entire story but
it's not going to be the overpowered
magma food or the even more insane
abilities of Los ope open on me so which
one is it well let's kick off things
with the Venom fruit which is an amazing
compliment to Luffy's rubber abilities
and you will see why in just a second
but as you might remember this fruit was
originally eaten by the warden of the
underwater prison imple down Magellan
here and it has unbelievably strong
abilities that are absolutely perfect to
pair up with Luffy's current Powers as
well and in case you forgot this is a
paramecia type devil fruit which allows
the user to produce different types of
poisons and during the imple down Arc
Magellan shot out deadly venom hydras
traveled quickly through Venom roads
made giant clouds of poison gas and even
Unleashed this terrifying Venom demon
which could literally melt through the
entire underwater prism now you may be
wondering why I've chosen this
particular one as the very first option
for Luffy's second fruit so let me
explain here imagine if we gave Luffy
just a stupidly overpowered devil fruit
to combine with his rubber food Powers
you know something like Admiral Kizer
was light fruit I guess well I could
imagine that Luffy wouldn't use his
rubber Powers as often if at all since
the light logo fruit is simply a godly
power and so instead of just combining
two superpower awful fruits kind of
making one of them useless I wanted to
pick devil foods that truly complemented
his already existing abilities plus we
have already discussed how powerful
Luffy would be with a different devil
fruit couple of times but giving him a
second devil fruit on top of his regular
one is a completely different Beast here
and I'm also gonna assume that Luffy has
his second devil fruit Powers right from
the start now that might not be possible
but he may have randomly eaten a second
Fruit by accident although it is of
course equally possible that he could
have just eaten a second one after black
did already showed us that it was
possible after Marine forts either way
he would have plenty of time to master
his second devil for Powers which is why
the Venom fruit is an absolute perfect
combo power for Luffy because he can
still keep his main fighting style of
punches kicks and headbutts but now he
can also coat his entire body with
deadly poison so that each of his
attacks deals way more damage than
before because the Venom that this fruit
produces is abs absolutely deadly if he
wants to straight up if you touch this
stuff it is basically an instant death
sentence not only that but having Venom
on his body would also be a huge
defensive boost since enemies would not
want to touch him at all he could also
use some of the ranged attacks like
these crazy poison gas balls that
Magellan uses during his first Clash
against Luffy on top of that as you'll
remember he could travel insanely fast
around the insanely massive prison using
these Venom roads and he could use
gigantic poison attacks that could take
out entire groups of enemies all at once
which would have just been perfect
during battles like at marineford or on
Fishman islands and so can you just
imagine how powerful this would make
Luffy his base form would be
ridiculously more powerful than in the
original story and there are a few
specific examples where the poison fruit
would make Luffy's life so much easier
in particular when he gets into super
long battles like the Epic Big 12 hour
Clash against the Mochi men katakuri or
the emperor kaido for these fights Luffy
could simply build up poison damage over
time which if you've ever played a game
like Pokemon for instance you know that
a poison buildup over time can kill you
just as reliably as a single Massive
Attack so the longer the fights go on
the weaker Luffy's opponents would get
and another example of this power making
a fight way easier is against the string
fruit user doflamingo because Luffy's
deadly poison here could easily melt
Luffy strings before they even had a
chance to cut him and I mean just
imagine how insane gear 5 poison man
Luffy would be there are so many crazy
things that he could do by combining his
Limitless imagination and Venom such as
making sticky Venom balls to throw all
around the battlefield or if he awakened
the Venom fruit as well then he could
make the entire environment a poisonous
and bouncy Minefield that would be
absolutely impossible for any enemy to
fight on and yeah there would be some
downsides to this fruit as well for
Luffy I mean first just like Magellan
Luffy might get some of the poison in
his food which could send him straight
to the toilet for a whole different kind
of battle but even more importantly
Luffy doesn't like to kill people as you
know and this deadly poison would
definitely lead to more deaths than in
the original story so unless Luffy can
somehow make a poison that just knocks
people out or paralyzes opponents which
not impossible I think with this fruit
then this actually isn't the perfect
second devil fruit for Luffy which is
why the brain food might actually be
even better for Luffy because I think we
can all agree that Luffy is pretty much
an idiot outside of fighting but if he
could learn and remember all of the
incredible things that he experiences
throughout the story then he would be
truly a genius in the world I mean
seriously he has the world's best
Navigator Helmsman engineer swordsman
musician cook and archaeologist all on
his crew so if he could learn from each
of them he'd be a literal perfect pirate
I guess Plus on top of that he might
stop getting tricked all the time by his
enemies although now that I'm thinking
about it I wonder if Luffy would
actually have to read for this fruit to
work so never mind I guess brain fruit
in the trash plus the head doesn't help
with fighting but before we get into the
next absolutely insane second power that
we could add to Luffy we first need to
clarify that we don't know if it's
actually possible for Luffy to eat two
devil fruits in the first place I mean
we were told in chapter 385 by this
random guy that eating a second devil
fruit would make that person's body
explode which by the way is the only
time we've ever been told this and this
could possibly be because the spirits of
the devil Foods themselves that are
allegedly in the fruits could possibly
not live together in the same body but
we don't really know for sure if that is
actually true that's why it was so
surprising when Blackbeard actually
showed us that he could use both the
darkness and the Tremor fruit at the
very same time however there are of
course a lot of other theories about why
he can do this for example his special
logia fruit or that Blackbeard might
actually be more than one person but I
also think that it would be absolutely
hilarious if just anyone could eat two
devil fruits and that the rumor may be
created by the world government was
false all along and so now back to Luffy
we're going to take our normal rubber
Straw Hat Captain feed him this devil
fruit and watch as he evolves into Chop
Chop Luffy and to show you just how
mind-blowingly perfect this power would
be for Luffy let's go back to this scene
at marineford where mihawk is about to
slice Luffy into swiss cheese now
luckily enough Luffy just throws buggy
in front like a shield and the clown
tanks the blow but in our new scenario
Luffy doesn't even need his body shield
in the first place since his chop chop
Powers literally make him immune against
damage from any type of Blade slashes uh
Cuts goodbye and even overpowered bites
or anything sharp like spikes are now
absolutely useless against Luffy so yeah
you might have thought I'm kidding but
this is actually a huge deal for the
straw hat captain since these types of
attacks are literally one of the main
ways that he is seriously injured in the
story for example when he was stabbed by
crocodile in katakuri or when he gets
bitten by Rob Luchi but of course this
incredibly new level of Defense wouldn't
be the only upgrade that Chop Chop Luffy
would get because now he can pretty much
fly as we see buggy do many times
throughout the story however he can only
use this ability as long as his feet
stay on the ground in fact the author of
one piece even Drew us this diagram once
to demonstrate exactly how it works
however with Luffy's combined Powers
with his rubber Powers his range might
extend even further than buggies since
he can stretch his body way further and
honestly I can see so many creative ways
for Luffy to attack if he can separate
his arms and legs that could simply
overwhelm enemies by attacking from so
many different angles plus his ability
to fly early on could help the crew
Scout which would have definitely come
in handy during this guy Pia Arc where
the crew was lost in the jungle also
Luffy might have been able to climb up
back to the arc Max seem way easier
which could have meant NL wouldn't have
been able to even summon his strongest
attack although on the other hand Luffy
might get way more distracted since he
can now fly and look around and there is
the very obvious weakness to getting
kicked in the nuts however there is one
big disclaimer for this fruit which is
that we don't know if this fruit is weak
to hockey or not for example if Miha
coded his Blade with haki could he
damage buggy though at the same time
kind of weird if he hadn't cladded in
hockey during the war with Marine for it
but if so then that would be of course a
major Nerf for this fruit but we aren't
really sure since we've never seen a
clear example of this though we are
explicitly told that he is immune to all
blades so there's a very good chance
that Hockey blade still don't affect
this fruit as well which you might
disagree with but really I think no one
can disagree with just how perfect these
next fruits are going to be for Luffy
and these are so overpowered in fact
that they surpass simple fighting Power
and take just Luffy to the insane next
level of overpowered that's because I'm
talking about the biscuit fruit and the
cook fruit which we're both introduced
during the whole cake island arc and
since both of them allow the user to
make an unlimited supply of food Luffy
will never have to worry about getting
hungry ever again which is undoubtedly a
perfect power for Luffy since he has
such a bottomless pit for his stomach
kind of just like how you're the perfect
person to subscribe to this channel for
more one-piece content just like this
but even unlimited food is not the best
power up that we can give Luffy because
this next devil fruit is going to take
things to a entirely new level and
that's because since Luffy usually
already fights with flying punches axk
kicks and slamming headbutts there is no
greater power boost than simply giving
him more arms legs and heads to fight
which means that Nico Robin's devil food
power is simply the greatest second
devil fruit that Luffy could possibly
eat I mean don't believe me keep in mind
that this fruit allows the user to make
copies of any part of the user's body
and place them anywhere within a certain
range which is just such an OP ability
to have especially for gear 5 Luffy as
we will see in just a second but there's
even more because For Fighting there are
just endless attacks that Robin uses by
sprouting limbs we have the famous
clutch slam and even super-sized
versions of all of these attacks and
these powers are also great in a
supporting role since Robin can make
copies of her eyes and ears to spy or
combine her limbs into things like Nets
and wings which allow her to fly and so
combined with his son got Nika fruit for
Luffy these Powers would absolutely take
his fighting style held to god tier
level he instantly has more arms and
legs to fight with so with his rubber he
could surround enemies with a storm of
punches and kicks that would just Crush
any Fighter's endurance kind of like how
katakuri made extra Mochi arms to
completely pummeloofy back on whole cake
Island and these Powers would also allow
Luffy to get around much easier since he
could fly across Islands or swing his
way through tight places like in pull
down but that's of course not even the
ultimate ability of this fruit because
the final power up that Robin showed us
in one almight even allow Luffy to use a
famous technique from another Ultra
powerful anime and that's because
Robin's strongest ability allows her to
literally make normal or giant-sized
clones of herself to fight against
opponents so just imagine Luffy busting
out the shadow clone Jutsu to make a ton
of copies of himself even in gear 5.
this would of course be especially
useful in brutal fights against some of
the strongest pirates in the world such
as when battles kaido I mean can you
just imagine a hundred Advanced
conquerors hockey fist slamming down on
the emperor really that fight might have
even been over before Luffy ever has to
unlock gear 5 and especially if Luffy
could combine his clones with his other
gear techniques I mean Luffy would then
be nearly Unstoppable though he'd have
to increase his stamina quite a little
bit to keep up with those powerful
clones as well plus I mean just imagine
having multiple luffies I mean man it
would probably break the world I can
just picture one giant Luffy throwing
down lightning bolts on kaido while
another giant Luffy Rains Down fiery
punches I mean with these two Powers
combined he could be literally an
Unstoppable Gods however even though the
flower fruit is undoubtedly the best
fruit to pair with Luffy's original
devil fruit powers that doesn't mean
that this version of Luffy is the
strongest that we could possibly imagine
because I have to admit that seeing
Luffy be flying around as a giant red
dragon for instance is just such an
awesome idea that I made a video about
what would happen if Luffy ate each of
the yonko devil fruits instead of his
own and you can watch that right here
thanks for watching and I will see you
in uh this one the next one